هو حكموا ولايه فلوريدا الحالم بقياده
امريكا روندي سنتس عمر
ومن تويتر حلق بمقطعه لينذر بمعركه
جمهوريه واخرى رئاسيه يتوسطها بين الرئيس
الحالي
وايضا لينفت الانتباه من داخل المنصه التي
كانت ترامب يوما ما ملكها
وبطريقه لم تعهد في الانتخابات اختار
ديسانتس تطبيق تويتر للمحادثات الصوتيه
لاعلان ترشحه برفقه ملياردير ايلون ماسك
لكن تنفيذها كان غير موفق لما شابه من
تاخير وتقطع صوتي وخلل متكرر في البث فتره
الذي عكف على تروس سوشل علق قائلا ان
اعلانه كان كارثيا
اذا هكذا انقلب حاله على الصفحات من
ديسانتس الى ديزاستر ليتصدر الوسم كارثه
تويتر لم يكن الخطا التقني الوحيد الذي
ادخلت سانتوس بموجه سخريه اذ ان الذنب
الذي ارتكبته الخوادم التكنولوجيه هو طرد
المغردين من المنصه في حال الضغط على
المرفق ذنب كان كثيرا بجعل بايدن ينتهز
الفرصه الرقميه معلنا ومن ذات المنبر ان
رابطه للتبرعات يعمل
تقول التعليقات ان ديسنتيس اصر على الظهور
في تويتر لمواجهه ترامب في عرشه السابق
وكذلك ليستهدف الفئه الشبابيه ففعلا ورغم
ما حدث حصد مشاهدات مليونيه والاخر من
المستخدمين شمت به هكذا جنت على نفسها
براقش
كان بامكانه اختيار عقد مؤتمر صحفي او حدث
او مسيره او ببساطه استخدام قناه
تلفزيونيه كبيره لكن اختياره انتهى بفشله
وبينما يرى مستخدم العصفور الازرق ان
ديسانتس اخفق الا ان اخرين قالوا انها
هفوات متعمده اي انه بشكل او باخر يحاول
ان يحدث الجلبه تماما كما كانت ترامب على
مدى سنوبات اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات